اعلنت الولايات المتحده تقديم مساعده
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بمليارين و200
مليون دولار امريكي تضم منظومات دفاعا
جويا للمساعده الجيش الاوكراني اقل
المتحدث باسم البنتا ان المساعدات الجديده
تشمل صريخ جافل المضاده للدبابات وصواريخ
خاصه براجمات هايمرس ومعدات عسكريه اخرى
من المساعدات الامنيه لاوكرانيا وهي عباره
عن
425 مليون دولار من السحب وفق التوفير
رئاسي بالاضافه الى مليار وسبعمائه مليون
دولار وفق مبادره الدعم الامني لاوكرانيا
ويتضمن اعلان اليوم قدرات مهمه للدفاع
الجوي لمساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
شعبها بالاضافه الى مركبات مشاه مدرعه
ومزيد من المعدات التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا
بشكل فعال بما في ذلك صواريخ جافلين
المضاده للدبابات وذخائر المدفعيه وصواريخ
خاصه براجمات هاي مارس